still less must this complacency which
of Jura science claim that such
rapturous haziness is superior to
science this prophetic talk supposes
that it is staying right in the center
and in the depths looks disdainfully at
determinate nacinda liberabit Lee holds
aloof from notion and necessity as
products of that reflection which is at
home only in the finite just as there
isn't and just as there is an empty
breath so too is there an empty depth
just as there is an extension of
substance that pours forth as an
infinite multiplicity without the force
to hold the multiplicity together so
there is an intensity without content
one that holds itself in is a sheer
force without spread and this is in no
way distinguishable from superficiality
the power of spirit is only as great as
its expression its depth only as deep as
it dares to spread out and lose itself
in its exposition moreover when this non
conceptual substantial knowledge
professes to have sunk the idiosyncrasy
of the self in essential being and to
philosophize in a true and holy manner
it hides the truth from itself by
spurting measure and definition instead
of being devoted to God it merely gives
free rein both to the contingency of the
content within it and to its own Caprice
such Minds when they give themselves up
to the uncontrolled ferment of the
divine substance imagine that by drawing
a veil over self-consciousness and
surrendering understanding they become
the beloved of God to whom he gives
wisdom and sleep and hence what they in
fact receive and bring forth bring to
birth in their sleep is nothing but
dreams
in Section ten Hegel's criticism of the
philosophy of intuition which we've been
following out for several of these
paragraphs is coming to a crux he's
going to make some of the most damning
criticisms and the ones that also reveal
what he is moving towards in in this
section so he's continuing this this
sort of line laying out what the the
opposed position the position that he
wants to criticize would be saying yeah
he calls it rapturous haziness that's
already a little pejorative but where is
he going with this he says that the
people who are doing this they feel that
this rapturous haziness is actually
superior to determinacy to the notion of
the grift through necessity to science
to a system and they're saying that
actually they are the ones who are
penetrating to the depth of things
they're the ones who have a grasp on
what's most real and by implication what
they're saying is that spirit belongs on
their side this stuff over here is not
where the real show is so to speak
that's not where where real philosophy
would go
it's where the philosophy of say a humor
content gone but or sort of conned but
not the really important stuff so he
says this complacency which of jurors
science it shouldn't claim that it's
superior to science it acts as if it's
superior science because science only
deals with the empirical world now this
is going a little bit further science
deals with that which is determinate
that which has boundaries that which has
structure those things that can be
arranged in relation to each other what
we call discursive knowledge discursive
thinking oftentimes you'll see people
you know these
they frame this in terms of right-brain
left-brain and they'll say yeah I'm not
so much conceptual discursive kind of
thinker I'm not a linear thinker they
like to say I you know I just sort of
intuitively put things together
I'm holistic so if Hegel were around
today this would be part of what he'd be
criticizing this is oftentimes when you
ask them what do you actually mean by by
a whole so they can't tell you they
can't even give you a general idea they
can give you a word and then after you
say well what what exactly does a that
word mean to you things start to fall
apart and the reason why this is the
case is because they're actually not
penetrating to depth they're actually
espousing a point of view which Hegel is
going to say is the opposite of death at
depth it's actually superficiality so
how is he getting to that he says um
just as there is an empty breath not
wrath as in breathing but breath as in
you know extension so there's an empty
death and just as there is an extension
of substance that pours forth as an
infinite multiplicity without the force
hold that multiplicity together so let's
stop and look at that that passage a
little bit what is he talking about
there a extension of substance so he's
using this term extension which was a
quite popular modern philosophy and you
know if you think about Descartes for
example the card talks about two kinds
of substance really three because
there's God but extended substance so
bodies everything that we can measure
and then mind whatever that happens to
be extended substance would be the stuff
that we're seeing here you know things
you can sense with the senses sight
hearing it's really interesting to think
about this in terms of computer stuff
because I'm going to take this video and
process it and I can actually see the
the sound waves at least a certain
representation of them and I can monkey
around with them I can do that because
that is extension in a certain respect
now Hegel talks about the possibility of
there being extension of substance that
pours forth as a finite multiplicity so
multiplicity means there's a number of
different things
finite of course you know it's not
infinite there's a certain bound to it
finite infinite the finite multiplicity
without the force to hold the
multiplicity together no actual
structure or force holding all this this
stuff together it just falls apart
becomes meaningless
it's what in Latin they would call you
know a heap a MOLLE of things and so
this is in no way different than an
intensity without content an intensity
without content so when these people
over here are talking about depth
because they've had some sort of
intuitive flash or experience which
isn't really an experience because
experience would be over here right it's
it's something that you just have to
feel man what they're really doing is
they're talking about a kind of
intensity that doesn't have any
determinate content that you can't
actually put your finger on that's why
it's so nebulous
that's why it can mean anything that you
want it to and really what is it
ultimately based on it's ultimately
going to be based on feeling rather than
thought they think that they're having a
higher thought than our ordinary mundane
stick-in-the-mud scientific systematic
thoughts but really what they're doing
is they're just sort of having some hazy
conceptions that are tied together with
feelings and there's no determinate
content to actually anchor anything in
or hold anything together and or dig in
further to or share with another person
in you know inter subjective manners so
it's something that can feel good or
feel meaningful or feel deep to one
but it doesn't actually have that it's
actually superficial and Hegel says the
power of spirit is only is it great as
its expression its depth only as deep as
it dears to spread out and lose itself
in its exposition so here's the really
interesting thing he's sort of saying
you guys have hijacked spirit over here
we're going to bring it over here where
it actually belongs unless you can
actually articulate things in
determinate ways start arranging things
and it's not to say that you actually
have to help full-blown science or
system worked out ahead of time but
unless you're being systematic in some
sort of way that allows you to actually
say that you're making some sort of
progress and pose some definite problems
for yourself and think of things in
conceptual terms and try to figure out
what the hell is going on in terms of
something must be the case you're not
really doing anything and you're not
really engaging with spirits spirits
actually on this side Hegel would say at
least for for now because that is what
spirit requires in order to articulate
itself and over and over and over again
in the phenomenology we're going to see
what we call shapes of spirit - Dalton
shapes of consciousness assuming some
sort of determinacy that doesn't turn
out to be the final story that turns out
to have some flaws in it that turns out
not to be the completed product but it
spirit has to take on determinate form
and shape or else it becomes it becomes
content less superficial the dialectic
stops and all you're left with is kind
of hazy feelings like it did something
cool so he says when this non conceptual
substantial knowledge professes to have
sunk the idiosyncrasy of the self an
essential being and the philosophy is in
a true holding manner it hides the truth
from itself because what's going on over
here
has eschewed as beneath it what's going
on over here it's actually deprived
itself of anything that would really
give it death and it's actually not
superior to what is going on over here
the the requirement to articulate itself
the requirement to measure itself the
requirement to make itself substantial
so he says it hides truth from itself
spurning measure and definition instead
of being devoted to God what is it doing
it's merely giving free rein to the
contingency of the content within it
into its own Caprice so the people that
think that they're in touch with God in
touch with the real and touch with the
Holy in touch with what is most valuable
what is absolute by doing the sort of
thing are really manufacturing their own
kinds of idols which then they feel good
about because why not I came from them
ultimately and it's suited to them it's
measured to them and then they're
surprised that other people don't get
into it and they can say well those
other people they're just you know
they're they're not in the know the
Renate sysm comes in by the way totals
you know side note but they're not in
the know they they're too stuck with you
know literal patterns and and discursive
knowledge and their two enemies get it
mixed up whether it's left brain and
right brain but one of them is the one
that's supposed to be linear and you
know good at figuring things out but not
very creative we're the creative types
over here Hegel say no real creativity
real connection to what it is define to
what is most real real uncovering of the
potential of human being it's not just
going to take place over here it's going
to take place through through this stuff
that's not to say that this is
everything but this is not going to be
something that one can just put aside or
denigrate or say doesn't matter this is
going to be
the stuff that has to happen in order
for spirit to actually understand itself
to articulate itself in time to develop
and that's what the phenomenology is
about
besides it is not difficult to see that
ours is a birth time in a period of
transition to a new era Spirit has
broken with the world that is hitherto
imagined and inhabited and is of a mind
to submerge it in the past and in the
labor of its own transformation Spirit
is indeed never at rest but always
engaged in moving forward but just as
the first breath drawn by a child after
its long quiet nourishment breaks the
gradualness a merely quantitative growth
there is a qualitative leap and the
child is born so like why is the spirit
in its formation matures slowly and
quietly into its new shape dissolving
bit by bit the structure of its previous
world whose tottering state is only
hinted at by isolated symptoms the
frivolity and boredom which unsettled
the established order the vague
foreboding of something unknown these
are the heralds of approaching change
the gradual crumbling that left
unaltered the face of the whole is cut
short by a sunburst which in one flash
illuminates the features of the new
world
we come down to a turning point a very
dramatic turning point where Hegel
seemingly is changing the subject he's
finished with talking about the
intuitive philosophy for a little while
at least he'll come back to it later on
and now he's talking about the times
again he's approaching this in a
different manner he says that spirit is
always moving on spirit is always
progressing so what does that mean that
means that in any given milieu it may be
you know sort of stagnant spirit that
has already reached the cusp of its
development and isn't going to go any
further and is actually going to begin
to decline and rigidify ossify or you
adapt you continue to change you react
to the new times and you do so not only
in a you know reactive way but in a what
we nowadays called proactively a
thinking way trying to make sense out of
the new manners he says ours is a birth
time and a period of transition to a new
era birth time that's a really
interesting way to think about this
something new is coming on the scene
it's not just a period of transition
that we're always engaged in transitions
it's a dividing point something new is
happening and he's not going to tell you
exactly what that is in this passage
that's coming a little bit later I want
to use this this schema right here to
talk about the metaphor and the basic
ideas between quantitative qualitative
these got going on which you say
ultimately culminate in a new world you
know bursting out like a sunburst you
know I think when he says a sunburst
imagine your it's a cloudy day and
you're going along outside doing
something and then suddenly the Sun the
clouds open up in the Sun just
brilliantly beams down upon you is
talking about that sort of dramatic
change
everything is illuminated everything
looks different in a sunburst it may
dazzle you too
you may not be able to take it in so he
talks about this as being this birth
time and he says spirit is indeed never
at rest but always engaged in moving
forward spirit has broken with the world
that it is hitherto inhabited and
imagined and that's a very important
thing to say not only his spirit
inhabited a world the world that it is
inhabited is partly the product of its
own processes of thought its own
imagination and its imagination is going
to be liberated in this as well
now the metaphor that he's using is of
quantitative growth of a child in the
womb you know you think about a baby and
its development from you know tiny
little cells all the way to to this this
incredibly complex thing which is a tiny
human being with a great big head that's
one of the things that differentiates us
from the other animals it's its organs
have become developed it's almost ready
to become as you could look at it as
free or independent of the matrix in
which it has grown which include not
only the mother who's been carrying it
around but also its you know I don't
want to say twin but but these organs
that go along with it like the placenta
these are almost sort of like crutches
that can be dispensed with
or use the Vic and shiney and praise a
ladder that you throw away once you
climb it which I don't think that can
Stein actually came up with I think
that's that's coming from mystical
literature but you have quantitative
growth and if you were only to look at
the quantitative growth you would not be
able to predict that there would be a
qualitative leap but there is and
there's a qualitative leap in all sorts
of processes where the quantitative can
increase as much as it want once it
reaches a certain point you've got
something new happening
you're in a new world you're in a new
condition this would be birth for a
child sooner or later the point of the
qualitative growth that it's undergoing
is not to just keep on growing and
growing and growing but for something
radically new something higher something
with greater possibility to occur
consciousness full consciousness the
consciousness of being an independent
being outside of the womb now of course
you can quibble and say well babies
aren't completely independent they have
to be changed and fed and all that you
got to kind of go with this metaphor
it's a metaphor right you have to think
what he's trying to get it there's a
fundamental difference between a baby
before birth and a baby after birth part
of that is in the nature of the world
that it's experiencing part of that is
in the liberation of its potentials what
you're going to take a long time to
develop granted
now why is Hegel saying this about his
own time and can we say this about our
own era more than 200 years after hegel
hegel saying it in part because he's
writing this at the same time them that
the Napoleonic Wars are taking place and
you got to remember that Napoleonic Wars
are not just a dynastic struggle between
European monarchs Napoleon is an emperor
but he's the Emperor of the French who
have had a massive you know decades-long
revolution that has seen the heading of
royalty the banishing of the church the
replacement of all of that by a regime
that was dead set on making everything
totally rational even to the extent of
imposing the decimal system on days and
months which didn't work by the way and
which had developed a new not only a new
way of doing things and articulating
politics and even down to you know
changing the order of military affairs
but had given people a different
conscience
you know the states in Europe could no
longer feel as secure about the cultures
they inhabited after the French
Revolution that's why it was such a
traumatic event Hegel is trying to make
sense out of this he's trying to say
what is the meaning of this new world
that we've been thrown into and he's
going to see his own philosophy as being
at sort of the the center the fulcrum of
that
but this new world is no more complete
actuality that as a newborn child it is
essential to bear this in mind it comes
on the scene for the first time in its
immediacy or its notion just as little
as a building is finished when its
foundation has been laid so little is
the achieved notion of the hole the hole
itself when we wish to see an oak with
its massive trunk and spreading branches
and foliage we're not content to be
shown an acorn instead so to science the
crown of a world of spirit is not
complete in its beginnings the onset of
the new spirit is the product of a
widespread upheaval in various forms of
culture the prize at the end of a
complicated torturous path and I've just
as variegated and strenuous and effort
it is the whole witch having traversed
its content and time and space has
returned into itself and is the
resultant simple notion of the whole but
the actuality of this simple whole
consists in those various shapes and
forms which have become its moments and
which will now develop and take shape
afresh this time in their new element in
their newly acquired meaning
continuing this metaphor of the new
world the new baby that has come on the
scene Hegel is going to draw out for us
some some conclusions from that some
cautions and first and foremost among
these is well you know when you have a
new child like I just pointed out in the
previous section that child is
vulnerable that child is not yet fully
developed we're different than other
animals you know for example a little
little deer or horse full can get up and
start moving about an hour so after it's
been born and its mother's taking care
of it it's it's not entirely fully
formed but it's it's pretty much a
little version of its mature parent
that's not the case for human beings it
takes us an awful lot of development
which can go off at different places and
get too drawn into cul-de-sacs where
development just won't take place
anymore and as we all know babies are
incredibly vulnerable creatures left to
their own devices they will they will
simply die they won't feed themselves
they will cry you know because they need
to be changed because they want comfort
and they are subject to what we might
call all sorts of predation either by
other animals by diseases by the
environment itself so we can't expect
that the new world is going to come on
the scene as an entirely fully developed
all of its potential you know completely
worked out and explored sort of entity
instead what we're talking about is a
new world in its immediacy and I've got
this arrow here you'll see why just a
moment
it's immediacy or its notion hiegel uses
this term notion in in several different
ways sometimes he uses it for the
beginning point of something
something that requires to yet be worked
out further to be developed to take
determinate shape but that too is its
notion so there's the notion at the
beginning and then there's the notion as
it develops and he says that what we're
talking about here is the notion of
science now that's kind of a weird thing
to say right it hasn't natural science
been around for quite a while by the
time that Hegel is writing you know
after all the modern era is really the
product of natural sciences and the
great advances in it from from the
Renaissance actually from from some
antiquity and also some of the Middle
Ages but if you know that's we can
quibble about that sort of thing let's
just pretend the party line from the
Renaissance on modern science has been
showing us a new way to see the world to
see ourselves to do philosophy who are
you Hegel saying that science is still
in its infancy well science doesn't
fully understand its own business its
own process and products and actually if
you look at the history of science
you'll see that that the scientists were
not always on the same page about
everything and they could get into these
tips where you know Newton and Leibniz
are developing the integral calculus
roughly about the same time and
you know they accuse each other of
having stolen the idea Newton more than
the liveness and the British empiricists
go with with Newton's formulation and
thereby set British mathematics behind
for centuries
compared to the Continentals I mean
science is a messy business when you
actually start exploring it when you
start looking at its history so Hegel
saying science the crown of a world of
spirit he doesn't just mean the Natural
Sciences and he doesn't just mean the
technology that's going to be based on
the Natural Sciences he means the
science is across the board so what we
would also call the human or social
sciences remember we're talking about
this in shopton here not just you know
the anglo-american notion of Sciences
the hard sciences we're talking about
the human sciences which are always
still in the process of developing and
discovering andrey articulating
themselves why because they're human
sciences because they're a little bit
more self-conscious about their own
history and their own development and he
would also include things that we no
longer call sciences like the
development of mathematics like moral
science that is the science of ethics he
would say that is part of the process as
well so science is not really yet fully
developed in his time it's more like the
new baby that's on the scene so he says
science the crown of a world of spirit
is not complete in its beginnings the
onset of the new spirit is the product
of a widespread upheaval in various
forms of culture the prize at the end of
a complicated torturous path and just as
variegated and strenuous and effort
Hegel's saying there's a lot of stuff
going on in my own time that you know
people have been putting things to the
experiment think again about the French
Revolution and this notion that we're
going to we're going to change society
itself that was not just about natural
science that was about what we call
social science about psychology
sociology these things even before they
had names people are working
and Hegel saying all of this stuff is
going on but it's going off this way in
this way in this way this way in this
way and and not everybody's on the same
page and they're actually arguing with
each other about quite a few of these
things great example in his own time
theory of color Goethe had one theory of
color Newton had another theory of color
they're both quite interesting
ultimately people want with Newton but
there's certain things about Goethe's
theory of color that actually make quite
a lot of sense
Hegel saying in order for it to really
be science in order for it to truly be
knowledge it has to be unified it has to
be a process by which rational beings
are coming to know about the this thing
that they call knowledge and the objects
of knowledge which include themselves
which include the knowing subject and
include what connects the different
realms of knowledge to each other
now that is just in its infancy at his
time it's a good question about whether
it remains in its infancy in our time as
well so he says what's going to happen
with with this and I put this this
question mark here Hegel talks about
this in terms of immediacy and whatever
you see that immediacy don't just think
about what is right on the scene
immediately on the spot think about a
lack mediation a lack of something else
which supplies context which supplies
explanation which supplies our
understanding of things and there's
going to be a lot of different things
that are going to mediate but what are
we going to move to from the notion to
mediation or mediate
that means that when we are actually
working in a truly philosophical in a
scientific manner things are always
going to be mediated there's going to be
no sort of raw we can start here and and
this is completely taken for granted
starting points that we're going to be
able to work with this is sort of a side
note and this is something that will
come up a little bit later on there is
something else that's going on in this
passage that's very important that ties
in with this whole notion of birth and
development he says that it's the whole
the totality which he has having
traversed its content in space and time
so it's got content right the terminus
things there we go and these have been
changing in space and time some of these
didn't exist and then begin to exist
some of these go off the scene and the
entirety the whole traverses itself
through space and time traverses all of
these content it returns into itself and
become the resultant simple notion of
the whole of the totality of the all of
the everything you may say what the hell
is he talking about here well where
we're headed with this is bringing in
the subject bringing in the thinking
subject as part of this process we're
the ones that are able to grasp the
whole or the totality as such and we are
part of that very whole and when we
think about this at first we form a
simple node
something which is not yet developed and
so we're usually going to do this by
taking some particular kind of content
and focusing it on that but really
strictly speaking we should be focusing
on everything at the same time it's very
difficult to do isn't it so he says the
actuality of this simple hole consists
in those various shapes and forms which
have become it's moments which will now
develop and take shape of fresh this
time in their new element in their newly
developed meaning so what he's talking
about there is saying that each one of
these has undergone a process of some
sort of development through human
history and that we're now at a point
where by grasping the whole and grasping
the entire process of development we can
see what happened with each of these
were in a we're in a position to see
better than the people who were involved
in the French Revolution just what was
going on what the real meaning of the
Revolution was these IV the whole they
were not able to have a full perspective
on it because it was still developing
now we're at the point in time where we
can at last have a truly scientific
understanding of all of human
development in politics law art religion
philosophy culture all the technology
all these sorts of things now
you can debate whether Hegel is at such
a point where you can make such a claim
but Hegel certainly thinks that is there
and this is central to his project